[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on the 3rd of August I'm
John Connolly The Spectators news editor
and your host for this week
coming up on the show
old school policing is back the past few
years Britain has largely given up on
low-level crime in Kitty balls this week
writes about the new super cops who are
trying to do something about that if you
enjoyed me on the show with Adam porgsby
deputy director of onward
yesterday Donald Trump was indicted in
connection with the January 6th storming
of the U.S capital the ex-president now
faces 78 separate criminal charges and
if found guilty could end up in jail
Freddie gray has the story
over in Canada conspiracy history is on
the rise in particular the story of the
abuse and mass murder of indigenous
children which has been endorsed
wholesale by the government despite a
troubling lack of evidence
why is Canada's government look to
sensor anyone who questioned this story
another Crackdown on History denies them
exacerbate the problem
the historian Robert teams joins me on
the show
finally dog attacks are on the rise in
Britain but who is to blame and will
rise campaign is point of things that
owners who are incapable of training
their dogs
some dogs simply not bred to be pets
help students are writer Ed West and Dr
Lawrence Newport academic and YouTuber
do subscribe to our YouTube channel
spectator TV is picking up thousands of
new subscribers every week and you
should be one of them just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon so you never
miss an episode
first up in our cover piece this week
our politics editor casing balls writes
about super cops this week the police
have promised to investigate every crime
a policy which was first rolled out in
Greater Manchester who are the super
cops and could the return of tough
policing win back Tory voters worried
about and social behavior Adam hawksby
deputy director of onward and Katie join
me now
Casey and Adam thank you for joining us
on The Spectator TV uh now Casey you
write a cup of Peace in this week's
magazine are super cops um we start off
by saying that the police quality is
going to be changing is quite soon in
the next few weeks they're going to be
investigating every crime
um for those watching you can possibly
thought if the police were invested if
you have a crime what's going on here
and what's cheerings I think it's fair
to say that most people would think that
it was not particularly novel concept
that the police would investigate every
crime however in the past few years
there's definitely a trend amongst many
of the police forces to actually go away
from investigating low-level crimes now
they will talk about austerity say this
is down to a lack of resources and and
this is reflected in the Public's view
there is a Hugo polled recently which
found that a majority of Brits think
that if when it comes to things for
example such as phones being stolen uh
bicycle theft they do not think the
police are going to investigate them and
they're right if you look at bicycles
their prosecutions I think it's under
two percent have actually been
prosecuted in the past year uh 90 don't
go close
um and therefore just as into the sense
that in a way some crimes have been
decriminalized even though actually if
you look at the ons figures when it
comes to headline crime Figures it's
spooling since 2010 it doesn't
necessarily tally with people's personal
experience so this is a shift uh of
course some would say it shouldn't have
been a problem in the first place and
the shift has come from one particular
police force is that right you can tell
us about it yes in this specific policy
originates not from a think tank and
Westminster or even a White Hall
department at so much as the fact that
Stephen Watson who is a chief Constable
of Greater Manchester police is
something that he brought him and he
took over that Force now at the time the
forces in special measures not doing
very well at all and it was one of the
various things he made the force do now
it has reaped rewards and there's now a
sense that what it did there which was
not only increasing obviously
prosecutions but also acting as a
deterrent means that the government now
want to adopt it nationally
Adam what do you make of the role aisle
and and do you think as well there could
be sort of a move towards listening more
to local police forces and introducing
policies nationally yeah I mean it comes
at the end of a very odd period of
conservative reform of police right
between about 2010 and 2019 you
basically had reform but without
investment and suddenly 2019 to now
you've got investment without real
reform you have Boris pumping a huge
amount of money into recruiting a load
of police officers what you're seeing
now I think is this really interesting
bottom-up reform that KT points to that
a range of different forces are
experimenting with how you can get more
from less some of that is about how you
can investigate all burglaries other
people are experimenting with what they
call Hot Spot policing so charging
police officers in some places that are
disproportionately responsible for Crime
so this sort of bottom-up innovation
seems to be a real Trend and I think
will well hopefully but the government
feed through into reduced crime do you
think the government of sort of
recognizing now that people's perception
of crime is becoming far worse and it's
becoming a bit of an important
initiative and as well hugely and I
think actually I'm anti-social Behavior
was a bit of a wake-up call for the
government so on with we've been doing
work in different kind of towns across
the UK to understand what their
priorities were in terms of leveling up
in Westminster I think people often
think of links about you know trains or
about you know new skills programs or
whatever else actually the number one
thing we heard was it was about
antisocial Behavior people being worried
about spending time in their Town
centers about things like shoplifting
burglary low-level crimes so that's why
I think it's ratcheted up in terms of a
political priority and policing is one
of the key ways you can address it and
in terms of other initiatives Casey you
mentioned your piece that um one
particularly the amount of time that
police spend on Mental Health call-outs
can you tell a little bit about that and
how that's changing yes so I think when
you look at the greater Manchester
example and that is one example of two
Constable's leading policy originally
that then becomes National and another
really good example is homicide police
and I think what's striking about both
greater Manchester and humberside is
they didn't come from a place in a way
I don't know the right way to say it but
luxury it almost came from a place of
desperation so both forces were in
really tricky positions they were not in
a good State and then therefore they had
to innovate to find a way out of it and
in humbicide one of the things they
looked into so when I switched to Chief
Constable there and he was saying that
he asked all his Force you know what are
the quickest things we can do and to try
and turn things around to have an impact
on what you can do and they said well
actually it's mental health call that's
because uh lots of the figures in the
community will say we want you to focus
on crime the police officers would
respond well sure but we are spending a
lot of time and ultimately going to the
hospital for those having a mental
health crisis and having to stay there
because of a legal and imperative and
that takes up time which you could be
using to solve crime so they embarked in
a program by which they dealt with you
know various
uh services to work how to offload the
burden and but if essentially led to a
situation where now about one in four
mental health goals are now served by
the homicide police but the rest are
dealt with through other services and
that's freed up a lot of police time to
the point that it's now going to be
taken on by the Metropolitan Police and
also them rolled out nationally and I
what I thought was quite interesting is
uh since it's been you know written
about it it's going to be rolled out
nationally there's been lots of people
saying well this is a dereliction of
Duty by the police what about these poor
people are they going to get lack of
service and they put that to the chief
Constable now he said in humbicide that
was not an issue the bigger question is
about making sure deadlines work to make
sure that other services are ready to
take on the burden and there's only now
that it's been covered nationally that
people are making that point and from
the community perspective who said most
people didn't even notice the change was
happening because they had the right run
time I suppose the question is do them
Matt and the other forces have the right
run time to prepare for this yeah I
wanted to ask Jessica about the Met Adam
I mean do you get the sense that they
could learn a lot more from other police
forces do you think what if you made him
be capable of taking these reforms as
well as yeah I mean look given that
public confidence is one of the key
things these reforms are targeted at you
know making sure the police are visible
that people believe they're going to
investigate crimes when they're reported
public confidence is the key challenge
with them and it hasn't necessarily
emanated just from low-level crimes
there have been a series of high-profile
incidents and uh instead of
mismanagement but it's gonna have to be
neighborhood policing investigating
level crimes part of at the Mets route
back to being a trusted police force
because as Katie says one of the
challenges is that polling recently said
about 40 of people wouldn't bother
reporting a crime if it happened to them
because they don't think it would be
investigated now that's a nightmare for
the future because you can't spot
patterns you can't spot Trends and you
can't solve crime so yes it's gonna have
to be a part of what the meta is trying
to do
um so I want to talk a little bit about
the sort of political angle of the yes
um do you think there's a rest of the
tour is that you know for example Andy
Burnham can take credit for the reforms
coming out of GMP and they've been
rolled out nationally they're sort of
sending to a Roundy thing to to their
than local Chief constables I I think
potentially I mean Andy Burnham was
Metro Mayo greater Manchester when the
police force fell into special measures
in the first place so that obviously
complicates the picture slightly he
played a role in appointing Steve Watson
which is uh you know widely been
applauded I think it's fair to say that
Watson is probably uh you know we're
talking about these super cops
um the conservative party's favorite
given he talks about an end to Virtue
signaling getting his policeman off
Twitter making sure they shine their
shoes there's all those elements there
and but in a way I mean I think partly
because Andy Burnham is quite
independent figure of the labor party
Kirsten's team often criticized him for
one and it might actually be quite
helpful
non-partisan endorsement of their policy
which is listening to the regions and
the regions driving National policy and
so there's always a risk on those things
but
um it's almost goes beyond Party
politics which is I think to lots of
people how they feel crime in their
Community is is
um might be something they vote on but
it's not so much about what's good for
the Tory party or the labor party
and therefore the Tories I think their
hopes on this do rest on the police
performing well I mean and but lots of
the end of the day I'm not thinking
about that they're just thinking how bad
is it in my area it seems interesting
out and that it's not police
Commissioners which have been placed by
the tools which into the media on these
reforms do you think that's an area that
possibly needs reform it's not working
as well as consent incumbent intended
when we introduced it so it's worth
noting that Andy burden is the police
and crime commissioner for greater
Manchester right and that's the key what
they've done is combine the police and
crime commissioner role which a lot of
people don't know who their PCC is but
they might know Andy Burnham or Tracy
braben in West Yorkshire is their police
and crime commissioner so I think the
next step is going to be for the
tourists to I don't know merge two of
their big great reforms right pccs on
one hand metromes on the other and just
have one single accountable figure
because then you know who the buck stops
with and that means you can hold them to
account when things are going wrong and
reward them when things are going right
and Katie ministers are the in the piece
that the toys have got some other crime
policies coming before the election
hopefully can you tell us about those
and about that what they're looking at
yeah if you look at the theory about how
to deter crime and resulting is composed
of a few factors but one of those is
severity and so making sure the
punishment is not just dealt with
swiftly the crime was investigated make
sure the punishment is severe enough it
puts off others and I think if we're
looking ahead to The King's Speech so it
will be in the next parliamentary
session crime is going to be a big issue
for the Tory party and it might be at
least two bills on crime and focusing on
sentencing now it's quite easy in some
ways for the Tory pies to talk about
sentencing the questions do they have
the prison places to make it possible
but that is going to be a big push and
also I think what we'll see from the
conservatives going into the Autumn is
more attacks on kirst Armor trying to
use his record
um in his role as DPP so prosecutions
and the suggest he is on the wrong side
when it comes to many of these debates
so
the crime stats might look good on paper
we've discussed on this podcast why
actually lots of people might not feel
it and but it's still an error I think
that the tourism they can have work in
their favor by the time of the next
election Adam do you think that they've
got time to turn around on crime I think
it'll be difficult and I think but as
Katie says there'll be a real desire to
create a dividing line here with labor
on that what might be really interesting
on policing is there will be parts of
the labor party I think that are very
uncomfortable with the kind of factor
Basics maybe quite Hardline approach
that's being described in some cities
where it's been introduced it's been
disproportionately deployed on ethnic
minority populations or poor populations
and so if it is the case there are some
MPS or members of the labor party are
uncomfortable with that that could open
up a fracture within labor that would be
interesting but there are a myriad of
different problems that need to be
overcome before that including not least
prison places and whether you sentence
more people you can have a place where
you hold them brilliant thank you very
much Beth
next can the tourists come up with a tax
offer to save them before the next
election case Andrews has taken a look
at the inheritance tax debate for a
politics column this week and she joins
me that
okay thank you for joining us on
spectator TV
um you're writing your column this week
about the fact that the tax burden is at
its highest points since the war last
year the entire leadership election was
all about cutting taxed about when you
can do it but now tax cutting has sort
of completely disappeared from the
agenda uh can you tell us why and and
what's going on there so I think to some
extent this is accidental policy because
as you say John uh last year during the
summer this time last year during the
Tory leadership race all the Tory party
could talk about was cutting tax Liz
trust and Rishi CNAC were both pledging
to cut tax but in very different ways
and the Liz trust argument won out she
was arguing for a deficit Finance tax
cuts uh which were a relatively small
piece of her spending agenda actually it
was the energy price guarantee that I
think really tipped things over the edge
but she was arguing for tax cuts now no
spending cuts to go alongside them Rishi
sinak was arguing we will have tax cuts
we have to fully cost them and I'm going
to do this over the course of the next
Parliament so a six-year timeline as
opposed to a couple weeks now what
happened really was neither policy was
enacted because Liz trust tried to bring
in her tax cuts and her borrowings Bend
agenda was rejected heavily by the
international markets
since then I think there's been an over
correction a real nervousness around
just the phrase tax cuts and if you say
even in the Tory party a lot of people
turn around and say you know and peace
will say do you not remember what
happened uh the last time we tried to
cut tax
um but that's not where the Tory party
would choose to be if it could the idea
that they are going to go into an
election year which as you say the tax
boarding is now encroaching on that
post-war high is not a good place for
the Tory party to be and as I write in
the column I think there's rather
Universal consensus now that that has to
change the Tories have to have an offer
on tax I think number 10 would agree
with that too but there's a big debate
going on right now as to what that looks
like and a huge question over how much
money they're going to be able to find
to implement and you mentioned your
piece that the debate is leaning towards
cutting inheritance tax uh in particular
why why inheritance tax why is this why
is this the one that everyone settled on
so it's very topical right now I you
know I don't think any decision has been
made and I'm not sure that it would not
necessarily be where she sunak or Jeremy
Hunt's number one tax to cut but there's
definitely a sense from some of those
grassroot MPS who are really focused on
appealing to to the party and throwing a
bit of red meat that inheritance tax is
the one to cut uh and I think there are
several reasons for that
um the first being that the public just
thinks it's a wildly unfair tax even
though so few Estates are affected by
inheritance tax recent polling just this
week from ipsos showed that um it is one
of the one of the the taxes that people
perceive to be the most unfair they just
think it's ethically wrong and you're
taxing money over and over again so you
can understand why people are
uncomfortable with that one argument
that I think does come from treasury
officials anyway is uh that they think
that an inheritance tax cut would be
less inflationary because I mean you can
use that money for what you like but
when you get your inheritance you if you
were lucky enough to get inheritance you
tend to think well that's not something
I'm just going to go and like spend on a
holiday and you people usually put that
towards something much more secure like
a mortgage or paying off loans and the
rest of it so you I think there's less
fear that cash will be sloshing around
the economy and as it has been with all
of our coveted spending as the
government's desperately trying to see
that inflation rate come down
um I'm not as convinced by that argument
frankly the idea that we would get like
a sprinkling of tax relief and that
would be heavily inflationary I I'm not
sure I buy but it is an argument going
around but perhaps the most compelling
one is the idea that labor won't copy it
uh because at the moment I mean
something the labor party doesn't like
to talk about anymore but it endorsed
the majority of Liz truss's mini budget
it endorsed most of those tax cuts they
don't talk about that anymore but labor
has a policy right now when it comes to
the fiscal side of things that they copy
the Tories they copy them roughly on
spending they copy them roughly on tax
they don't want to be seen to be doing
anything radical they think this is a
good way to win
and Rishi CNAC has been trying to show
some of those differences between the
parties recently particularly on green
energy policies I think a lot of MPS
would like to see him go further on tax
I mean so that's one way straw a
political distinction but on the
economic front do you think if you're
going to go for cutting taxes is
inheritance tax the way to go in your
view
well um it doesn't bring in a lot of
money to the treasury it's about six
billion pounds a year and some people
use that as an argument to to cut it but
I think the question is if you can find
6 billion worth of efficiency gains and
savings do you want to slash inheritance
tax or do you want to take a penny off
of income tax you're talking about
roughly the same amount of money that
would be needed and as I say in the
piece I think this is the debate right
now because
look we could be in a world say next
Autumn where the public finances are
looking good where we've got some
meaningful growth where the rate of
inflation has really come down and the
numbers look great we could be in that
scenario the current data doesn't
suggest we're going to be in the best
case scenario so I don't think any MP
sitting around right now assuming
they're going to have
tens of billions to cut all different
kinds of tacks they are going to have to
probably hone in on a few and that's the
debate do you go for that sort of red
meat to the Grassroots inheritance tax
you know people hate this it'll create
headlines or do we go for the tax cut
that will actually be far more
broad-based and affect far more people
um and and I think that's the debate
playing out because uh ministers
secretaries of State this month are
being asked to find those efficiency
gains
um asked to find those savings part of
that is to pay for the public sector pay
raises that are coming in which are
estimated to cost about 5 billion but
part of that is looking at like how much
money are we going to have for tax cuts
next year where can we find the cash
depending on what that number adds up to
is going to be what we're looking at
when it comes to tax cuts because I
Rishi CNAC is always talking about
trade-offs and and you know this was
this great debate with Liz Truss It
would be so wonderful to grow the
economy we we must go for growth
policies and and frankly we don't have a
lot of those right now but even if the
government were going hard on growth
policies they probably wouldn't be
coming into effect for a few years so if
you want to cut tax responsibly next
year in a way that doesn't upset the
markets again you're going to need to
finance them you're going to need to
find the money that's probably going to
come down to spending restraint so how
much they actually find is going to
probably equate to the tax cuts we get
and uh where she's seen that is
discovering as prime minister it's
really hard to get your MPS to commit to
Rolling back the size of the state do
you think it's something then that needs
more direction from number 10 about
drinking the state
um well look Rishi cnx language is has
always been quite clear on this and and
when he was Chancellor he would often
you know insist that if you're gonna
have this great spending pledge you're
gonna have to have the money to go
alongside of it he was he was always
making that trade-off argument I think
the difficulty for Rishi CMAC now and
for his Chancellor Jeremy Hunt said it's
all good and well to be like we have to
make these tough decisions because you
know the markets were very uncomfortable
it's going to be painful for a while we
have to get the rate of inflation down
but then in your budget you're spending
lots of money and you're giving away way
more subsidies around things like Child
Care well not actually liberalizing the
market you're just spending the money
you're growing the state without those
pro-growth or forms at some point that
Narrative of well I'd like the state to
be smaller you know tough choices kind
of morphs into well why why are you
growing it then
um and and so you know I I think number
10 it's not simply about the narrative
on this it's the actual policies that
they're going to have to grapple with
going into the Autumn statement and the
next budget are they going to keep
spending money or are they going to
prepare to cut some tax brilliant thank
you very much Kate
[Music]
hello and welcome to women balls where I
Katie will speak to today's Trailblazers
foreign
[Music]
was in diced on Tuesday in connection
with the January 6th storming of the
capital could the ex-president really
end up in prison if found guilty could
even win the next election from a jail
cell Freddie gray joins me now
Freddie thank you for joining us on
spectator TV great pleasure John um I
was saying I think it seems a bit like
deja vu at the moment we're back again
talking about Trump facing criminal
charges but what are the latest
indictments and what is he facing it is
it is a little bit like from Groundhog
Day isn't it uh well the latest relate
to uh January 6th and special prosecutor
Jack Smith who's hounding Trump on all
sorts of fronts
um has uh brought four charges against
Donald Trump
um
the main one is a conspiracy to defraud
the United States
uh and alongside that the conspiracy
defraud the right to vote of every
American citizens and that relates to of
course Donald Trump's great tantrum
after uh the 2020 election and the way
in which according to a lot of people he
encouraged and incited uh the Riots of
January 6th which is now Infamous
um there are no Insurrection charges
which is quite some important because
probably the only way in which he could
be debarred from running from office
would be if he had been found guilty of
insurrection I didn't listen to happen
it's not a realistic possibility so you
have this situation now where Trump is
facing 78 counts 78 uh counts criminal
counts uh against him and the Civil uh
trial which is the rape case in New York
which is
seems quite spurious to a lot of people
but it's still ongoing
uh and he is still
far far ahead
in the polls to be the Republican
nominee it's not just trumpists who
rally around him because they've already
rallied around him it's actually quite a
lot of republican-leaning Republican
people who do feel this is a
politicization of Justice who do feel
that Donald Trump has a point and when
they're asked about it in pulse they
tend to support him more
uh after one of these indictments comes
out well he mentioned he's being hounded
by Jack Smith I mean do you think
they're right to think that that at
least some of this is politically
motivated the charges against him or
well it's funny with Trump I always
think that what I think doesn't really
matter because I mean I think if you
want to do what I think uh I think the
worst thing Donald Trump did as
president was to uh refuse to accept the
results of the 2020 election I mean
Richard Nixon uh in the 1960s thought
that he had been robbed of the election
by JFK and he actually had quite good
reason to think that
but he accepted the results uh and I
think it's an important part of the
democratic process even if it is a
little bit dodgy it's not totally
compromised her and you should accept uh
the result of it the fact that Donald
Trump didn't
was a bad thing uh he behaved recklessly
he did encourage people to think very
conspiritable thoughts
um and he did undermine the Democratic
process I think Americans and Brits when
we talk about Mary who can get a little
bit pompous about process we don't have
to all believe
election results you know we're not
that's not some sort of
um divine order that we have to accept
them and the fact is Democrats have
repeatedly refused to accept election
results when Republicans win they didn't
accept Donald Trump winning They didn't
accept George W bush winning
um it it's it's slightly pompous all
that talk I think so I'd I'd try and get
away from that and then maybe look at
whether these in criminal indictments
have any value I think in this
particular case while Trump no doubt
behaved badly
uh recklessly as I said
um what the indictment needs to prove is
what it claims which is that Trump
willfully knowing that he was spreading
lies about the election
uh tried to claim that it was stolen uh
I don't think they're going to be able
to do that I don't understand Trump's
brain nobody does but the fact is I
think Trump believes the election was
dodgy and therefore the fact that he
still does uh means that you can't
really accuse him of of willfully
engaging in a conspiracy I mean do you
get a sense though this could all very
much backfire for Trump's enemies in the
sense that if he gets off these
particular criminal charges he will
certainly see that as a Vindication of
his actions on January 6th it's very
hard to say I mean given the number of
uh charges in these indictments it's
possible that he will go down for him
will he go down in time for the election
that's a difficult question to answer
um if he does and runs from prison could
he run a successful campaign
constitutionally he could you can run
from behind bars Eugene Debs did it in
the 1920s he won a million votes
um so all sorts of imponderables uh are
going on here what do you think is going
through some Democrats Minds when they
look at this would they like a trump
Biden contest with Trump facing criminal
charges or do you think they're sort of
wary as well about how these charges
perhaps making Trump into sort of a
martyr for certain sections of of
America I think there are mixed thoughts
going on in the minds of Democrats and
Democratic strategies I think at one
level they think yes Trump as the
nominee is good for us because that
drives out the anti-trump vote which is
huge uh and there's no point
underestimating that it's a very
significant thing
and at the same time they'll be looking
at the polls if you look at polls
comparing DeSantis against Biden with
Trump against Biden Trump actually fares
a little bit better right
um so it's possible that in the Run of
an election campaign DeSantis is a more
normal politician without all these
criminal indictments hanging over him
would fare better but that's a difficult
judgment call so I think
um I remember Megan Kelly saying to me
on spectator TV uh in answer to this
question be careful what you wish for
that's what I'd say to democratic
strategists who think Trump is the ideal
nominee if the economy
goes bad leads to indications that the
American economy is actually going quite
well but as the economy turns bad and
you have Trump versus Biden there's a
very significant chance as Neil Ferguson
said in The Spectator cover piece
recently that Trump will win and become
president again he sort of reminded of
trump of Democrats willing Trump to get
the Republican nomination the first time
round actually and if the whole coming
collapsing down because they originally
thought he'd be a better opponent well
that's that's a very that's a very good
point the interesting thing is is this a
repeat of 2016. uh and I don't think it
is in many ways because I think the
atmosphere is different because Trump in
2016 was mind-blowing I mean he still is
in many ways but but it was all so new
and and it excited a lot of people and
got people interested in politics who
weren't interested and drove outloads of
people who don't normally vote
in 2024
yes Trump's movement is much bigger
but our independence and moderates
um as interested
in the kind of trump the justice system
is against me rhetoric
I think that's a that's a question that
that's yet to be answered and you
mentioned Trump's one of Trump's appends
in the Republican race Mike Pence who's
who's come out against Trump now and and
is sort of revealing his memos from his
time in the White House the other I
remember to say his Republic other
Republican candidates opponents haven't
made much hay of his criminal
convictions
um and do you think that's a mistake
that they're not making more political
Capital out of it uh I don't think so no
because I think uh politics is tribal in
America now and I think that
um Pence I'm not quite sure what his
strategy is it seems like he's
cooperating with the special broskies of
Jack Smith
um and he will probably give some sort
of statement in trial maybe witnessing
trial uh and say you know recount or
he'll have notes of what his
conversations with Trump at the time and
the prosecution and Pence will try to
paint Mike Pence as vice president as a
sort of honorable man uh you know being
put under pressure by this demonic
forces Donald Trump
um I don't think that's going to
convince a lot of people Mike Pence
sucked up to Donald Trump for four years
yeah uh in the most Orleans manner
possible
um and now he wants to be president but
he's on three percent in the polls I
didn't quite get what he's thinking as
to whether this will flip the script to
him because Trump's support is around 35
to 40 percent of the party now or people
that vote Republican uh that's not going
to change and doesn't there's nothing
that seems to be shifting that brilliant
thank you very much Freddie next in
Canada proposals to censor historical
denialism are having a chilling effect
on freedom of speech the Cambridge
historian and founder editor of the
history reclaim project Robert Toombs
has room for the magazine this week
about Canada's disturbing treatment of a
story about the mass murder of
indigenous children he's with me now
Robert thank you for joining us on
spectator TV you write about a
fascinating subject in this week's
magazine about the sort of killings or
alleged killings of indigenous peoples
in Canada
um before we start off maybe it gives us
a bit of a background and about how you
became interested in the subject
yourself
yes well I um um I set up a group called
history reclate which I hope all
spectator readers are Avid readers of we
have a website
um and what we do is to try to combat
the ideological abuse of history as we
see it as we know there is a there's a
sort of widespread attempt to retell
history to to we would say to distort
history in order to pursue certain
ideological and political AIDS
and so some Canadian friends or Allies
got in touch with us and we started
reporting on this whole question
relying on their expertise and they are
well-known Canadian historians who have
been
well I suppose in a way fighting back or
at least resisting the attempt to to
silence them because the I think it's
called the Canadian historical
Association did try to shut up all its
members and stop them from discussing
this and put out a statement saying that
you know this was a this was all factual
and what they said was factual is um a
whole set of accusations
that indigenous children
had been um had been killed either
murdered died of abuse died of in awful
circumstances or through neglect and
that this ran into hundreds or even
thousands of children actually one of
the stories going around was that the
queen and the Duke of Edinburgh had also
killed a dozen indigenous children on a
state visit but this story has not been
as it were officialized right but the
other stories have been more or less
well you almost universally accepted by
the Canadian government by the Canadian
state by the the whole sort of set of
Institutions that that are guardians of
you know the public of public culture so
the story that thousands of children had
died or been killed
um and had been secretly buried this was
also part of the story so you know you
have to imagine there are schools for
mainly for indigenous children or
entirely for indigenous children
boarding schools run by various churches
the Church of England was one and indeed
the archbishops came to be apologized
the Catholic church was another various
Protestant churches had were also
running schools
and uh the story was therefore that the
the teachers including priests nuns all
the rest had been killing children in
some cases or at least a diet killing
them by neglect and then secretly
bearing their bodies in Mass Graves
palette now you might say well would
anyone believe this story and the answer
is everybody officially believes it and
the Canadian government for example
ordered the national flag to be flown at
half-mast for five months they've given
tens of millions hundreds of millions of
dollars even in compensation they've
made huge grants of money to search for
hidden Mass Graves and as far as I know
none have ever been found
I mean what what set this off again was
the
Discovery in inverted commas of soil
irregularities by a young anthropology
researcher who had a ground penetrating
radar kit and who found in an orchard in
British Columbia what she said were
unusual soil irregularities
well some people would say in an orchard
that may well be due to the the tree
roots or something but it was
immediately assumed that this was the
grave of and I'm not quite sure where
the number came from this was the grave
of 215 children who had been secretly
buried in a mass grave
now you might think well wouldn't this
immediately be investigated by the
police wouldn't it be wouldn't it be
excavated to find evidence of what would
after all be be murder in fact no
investigation has ever been done no
human remains have been found and it
seems that no investigation will be
carried out so you might say well
are people relieved that these stories
appear not to be true and the answer is
and no because they've been officially
accepted as true and I think partly this
is because of a an understandable
reluctance to question the story of
survivors as they're called
um but as we all know as we've known in
many cases in this country if you start
believing what survivors tell you
implicitly without any kind of backup
you get all sorts of miscarriages of
justice and in this case it seems to me
you've had a miscarriage of Justice on a
huge scale in Canada
but there are big interests involved now
Financial through compensation and also
ideological because these schools were
the were the symbols of a policy of
integration
now there is no doubt that many of the
schools were were asked for by
indigenous groups until very recently
living indigenous leaders praised their
schooling experience crash no none of
that can be said they're regarded as an
instrument of cultural genocide
and indeed even of real genocide because
if these stories were to stack up you
know thousands of children killed then
you'd say they're not it's not just
cultural genocide it's it's literal a
physical genocide and that's one reason
why the story has has become almost
impossible to contest so there are a few
Brave historians who've been saying well
the evidence is that there are no
missing children there are complete
records of every child and although
children did die in these schools and at
some periods rather more than in the
general population right it's usually
due to things like tuberculosis which
was common in indigenous communities
there are records of every death often
they died in hospital or they were sent
back to their home reservation their
homes to to be looked after and died at
home so the idea that they were kind of
Hidden Away in schools and were dying or
like flies in schools is simply not true
and can be shown not to be true but that
means seems to make absolutely no
difference to the Orthodox View and the
thing that is most I think most
alarming in one sense and this is why
you asked me to to speak about this and
to do an article on this is that the the
the the woman who was the uh director of
the The Truth and Reconciliation
committee which was set up to
investigate these claims
um has said that this should be treated
as denialism and it should be made
subject to criminal and civil sanctions
so if you say I don't believe these
stories or if you say there's no
evidence that this is true or if you say
the evidence is that most of these
claims are provably false then she wants
you to be prosecuted and the Canadian
Justice Minister has said okay
politicians say all sorts of things we
know that he said he's open to this idea
so what what you actually have had is is
the Justice minister of Canada saying
that he's open to the idea of
Prosecuting people who are trying to
defend Canada against charges of
genocide you think there's another this
self-flagellation from bodies from
institutions from politicians about the
our history is sort of unique to the
west and we're the only place that that
does this now is there something unique
to us going on at the moment where oh I
think it's pretty unusual yes
um yeah I mean you can say it's it's the
right thing to do facing up to your
history is the right thing to do
admitting that you did bad things is the
right thing to do and doing what you can
to repair them is also the right thing
to do I mean the Germans to some extent
did it after the second world war well
you could say they they didn't really
have much choice in the matter but they
did and you know German children talked
about the Holocaust and all the rest the
Russians have never faced up to their
past and I think we would say that's one
of the things that makes the Russian
State rather dangerous they they don't
admit what happened under Stalin that
it's denied for usually denied in style
entries as a hero and so on
uh the the Chinese don't accept
of course they deny what happened at
chairman Square they they don't admit
what happened under Mao the Great Leap
Forward tens tens of millions of people
dying of starvation all that's hidden
away because it serves their purposes to
present themselves in a nationalist way
but we've gone to the Other Extreme in
in in the English-speaking World
particularly in that the the Orthodox
view now is that we have been terrible
people the terrible history have done
terrible damage to the world and we
should be very ashamed of ourselves and
the Russians and the Chinese love this
Putin has referred to it in his some of
his speeches
um the the Russian foreign Ministry put
us a long piece the other week about
Bridget Britain's Colonial sins and
saying how it was good that this was now
being looked at uh it seems to be the
Wagner group is going to be very pleased
by this because it's used politically
yeah against us and I would say against
the interests of of democracy and of
democratic countries and it does
undermine in in in Britain certainly in
Canada in Australia in America any sense
that these countries have any any
positive achievements and that they are
in fact Democratic communities who are
doing their best to to to to live in you
know a decent Collective life and this
is constantly saying that no that's not
true you're all racists you always were
racists in the past your racist now
you're racist in the future it's all
about white privilege it's all about
colonialism and so on and this has to be
destroyed and as one of my colleagues
said
um
if you deconstruct the West what is
going to replace it yes things much
worse yes I mean in the peace Robert you
use the word heresy to describe those
who sort of disagree with this weight of
Orthodoxy do you think there's almost a
religious zeal
well let's say there is a Zeal that is
rather like a religious steel
um you know some people are reminded of
different periods of History you know
I'm reminded of the Reformation period
in which again I suppose you could say a
great cultural upheaval and a great uh
you know a new technology the printing
press and and conflicts in in the world
make people start looking around for
scapegoats you know witches Heretics uh
and this is this does seem to be a kind
of psychological process by which by
which we cope with with with complex
periods of change
and in a way that I think few of us
would ever have imagined possible in in
countries like Britney
um there are attempts you know and
successful attempts to censor people uh
to punish them for their for their ideas
and not only I'd and of course not ideas
that are Criminal
and not ideas that are even wrong it
seems often seems to me that it's a much
worse sin to to say things that are
obviously true
because that's terribly embarrassing for
those who are upholding the Orthodoxy
um it's it's um but you know for people
to be in some cases
thrown out of their jobs you might say
is a relatively
um mild it's not like our understanding
when you get put it in the back of the
head but nevertheless people's lives
have been turned upside down
um they've been attacked publicly yeah
um they've been intimidated many people
are intimidated into making fulsome
apologies for things they haven't done
or else just self-censor and I think we
know that that various surveys have
shown how common self-censorship is now
and of course we've seen in the
grotesque case of of Coots and Nigel
farage how this is now spreading you
know it used to be a thing that that
happened in universities you know if you
if you said the wrong thing you might be
cold shouldered in the common room and
that kind of thing or you might not get
promoted or your book contract might be
canceled but now you you think well is
anybody
um immune from this kind of you know
Petty persecution but which can actually
wreck people's lives I mean have do you
think you've seen that in your own
discipline now that people will shy away
from certain topics of research oh yeah
I know it will be yes they'll be
slandered for it I mean yes definitely
um okay I don't think England is
anywhere near as bad as America probably
Canada which I don't know as much about
Australia New Zealand
um I mean I think the culture wars here
are less
um are less bitter so people are still
talking to each other but you know
everyone in academic in academic history
knows that there are some sorts of
subjects that will do your career good
to write about and there are some
subjects that will not do your career
good to write about
um and in some cases it might mean that
you'd you'd be if not dismissed you
would certainly you'd not be promoted we
all know the case now of Kathleen stock
as a philosopher not a historian but
that sort of thing can happen and I
think very many people and you know
those of us who work or at least who've
stumbled into this area and who have
become involved in it as as you know
history reclaimed and so on were quite
often told by younger colleagues that
you know I'd love to write something for
you or I you know I agree with what you
say but I have to be very careful you
know I remember one young
um political scientist saying well you
know I'm I have to think carefully about
this until I've got a family
I've got I've got a you know I need I
need a job you know put food on the tape
yeah and we know you know people who've
had book contracts canceled well you
know again I say it's not it's not good
it's not being sent to a concentration
camp but if you've spent several years
working on a book and it's been it's
accepted by a publisher and all of a
sudden they write to you and say um
sorry we're canceling your contract
because some of our staff don't like
what you've written you know that's
happened to a number of people brilliant
thank you so much Robert
and finally they're a much-loved
household pets in Britain that has been
an alarming rise in dog attacks lately
mostly by the American Bully XL breed if
we lost sight of how dangerous some dog
breeds can be joining me is writer Ed
West an academic and YouTuber Dr
Lawrence Newport
Ed Lawrence thanks for joining us on
spectator TV now um Ed you've written a
piece this week uh coffee houses it's
been our most read piece I think about
wonderful um the most dangerous dog
breeder we could ever think of the
American Bully XL um there's been a 50
increase in Hospital admissions in the
UK for dog bites uh what's going on here
can you tell us a bit about it well the
over the last five years and in
particular the last two years there's
been a big Rise
um both in fatalities which are still
relatively small
um but also injuries and particularly um
surgery for uh which tends to sort of
reflect like the most vicious attacks
rather than you know like hand attacks
um and a huge amounts of this is down to
one particular breed which is related to
um both the stuffable terrier and the
Pitbull the patent with the pit bulls
you know is banned in Britain but has
managed to
um avoid being classified under the
dangerous dogs act and so it's become
increasingly popular and many people
will notice these dogs in their area
um these are kind of very very big like
double or staffy almost in some ways
um they often look not very scary and
you know the funny thing is that the
background story is that lots of the
people
um who run also like adult charities in
the Kennel Club are completely in denial
about the the link between breed and
attacks and it is
um and and there have been lots of very
high profile um
very very horrific dog fatalities in the
last six months and they almost
invariably in fact it all involved this
one particular route so largely written
a big piece about the American Bully XL
I mean it seems like it's almost come
out of nowhere uh where is this breed
come from and why has it been why is it
so dangerous in your view
um so the breed seems to have uh been
imported from America around about three
four years ago
um it really gained popularity I think
over the pandemic there is no good
figures on this but you can kind of draw
some conclusions from the attack figures
unfortunately as to when about a dog
hits majority age and then we start to
see these attacks pick up in about 2021
and then really severely 2022 and um
even um this year as well so far
um I would pick up that uh as Ed says
they they were originally bred from
American Pit Bull Terriers and American
Staffordshire Terriers American
Staffordshire Terriers are different to
English Staffordshire bull terriers in
that um it's basically just a sanitized
name of the American Pit Bull Terrier in
the US that allows you to kind of um
I sign it up to official kennel clubs
under that kind of official name until
like the mid 70s so they were they were
taken from what is essentially a
fighting breed and in the U.S
dogfighting went on for a very long time
uh it was still legal in most places
until the mid 70s and um even in 2005
there was very little enforcement to
stop it and these dogs uh the largest of
these dogs were then bred with each
other and there were claims maybe some
Mastiffs were mixed in but that's not
actually easy to find it looks like a
lot of them are heavily Pitbull and they
are um bread and into bread
um and sometimes quite aggressively
inbred in order to get larger and larger
muscle mass and larger size so as where
a pit bull might max out about 20
kilograms and American Bully XL is
around about 60 kilograms
I mean it seems kind of remarkable that
this dog hasn't been banned yet I mean
Ed so the rsdca say on this we believe
focusing on the type of dog rather than
their individual actions as a flawed and
failing approach dog aggression is
highly complex and taking a breed
focused approach is fundamentally flawed
I mean what do you make of that is it is
it dog ownership or is it is it both and
a lot of this comes down to you know the
blank slate idea which is
um
sort of overwhelmingly dominant in in
Western Society generally this is a
denial of the genetic input into
personality
um which is very widespread about humans
um I mean we are in urban Society so
people who grow up in urban societies
are small families can kind of become
unaware of the fact that
um most in fact all traits are partly
hereditary so if you bred
any animal for certain traits repeatedly
those traits have become much more
extreme so dogs have been deliberately
bred this way so if you get aggressive
dogs and they may the rest dogs they're
going to become more aggressive over
time and it's the same with any dog I
mean I mentioned my own dog which is a
Portuguese budango I'm not a fan of I
have to say
um who's you know very very good with
kids as as long as you're not a fox in
which case still kill your kids and you
know she's been very very well trained
and everything
um but she will always try to attack
small animals she's just at Hunter by
natural nature um and that's just
um the way it is so you can't really
just say oh you know a good
uh you know good owner will make these
dogs aggressive because lots of the
fatalities have actually involved quite
you know pretty good owners who did all
the right things I mean the dog walkers
the classic example she was a perfectly
nostalgic yeah it was horrification she
tried to she warned other people to get
away whether it's supported there's all
this kind of stuff about oh you know
she's attacked by all these other dogs
those are dachshund maybe like a Cocker
person thing and it obviously didn't
make sense because you know that's just
even if the Daxton wants to attack you
it wouldn't be able to overpower you
um and these dogs have a very you know
it's a combination of both aggression
and Incredible strength
um with um so you know it's completely
flawed to just say it's the owner it's a
mixture of genetics and upbringing which
um which makes adult violent so so
Lawrence what do you think we can do
about this I mean can you ban a breed
like this or is it are these things very
easy to circumvent do they just mix them
with other kinds of dogs and that kind
of thing
yeah so um this is uh also a frequent
objection from um groups like The rspca
and others which is that one they claim
that breed doesn't matter and two if it
did matter which we can see from
statistics cross-culturally it does
um even if it does you can't do anything
about it the the problem with that is
that
um there are at least two different
routes which seem to be quite effective
we've banned Pitbull types actually not
just a Pitbull breed we banned Pitbull
types since 1991. because the government
hasn't updated the guidance on what
defines a pit bull
um and a pit bull types of all the
crosses and for instance American Bully
excels and American bullies probably
fall under this as well really
um the guidance if it was updated could
reflect this and these dogs just simply
wouldn't have been able to be imported
into the country originally the fact the
government hasn't updated the guidance
essentially created a loophole where
these dolls could then be imported
and now we see the effects and in fact
we can see how good and how effective
um Banning uh people types has been in
that the moment we get back a Pit Bull
type dog our attacks Skyrocket which
tells us that the dangerous dogs act
contrary to a lot of kind of opinion
seems to have worked pretty well for
quite a long time and keeping numbers
quite low
um the other option is if the government
doesn't want to update guidance they can
today at any point add the American
Bully Breed to the banned list
um through the signature of the
environment secretary it doesn't take
much time at all does that mean the dogs
are put down if that happens all right
um so the government has a list of
options that they can then uh pursue so
that would be you can do anything from
you can enforce leads and muzzles in
public neutering you can make sure that
people can't sell the dog so you don't
get like a breed uh people who are
breeders then have to either keep the
dogs
um or for instance people who currently
own them can't then sell them on they
have to keep them they have to look
after them they have to have them
neutered and muzzled in public the 1991
um band of pitbulls did have people have
to apply to courts to prove that their
dogs weren't dangerous of which by the
way actually a large number of dogs were
shown not to be dangerous and they could
keep them but there was about a thousand
dogs that the court saw which they said
were outwardly aggressive and were
deemed dangerous
um but the government has these kind of
options to hand if they pursued that
path
so it seems like there are options the
government hasn't acted yet do you think
this sort of ties into the very deep
seasons of British love and of animals
that we almost can't accept sometimes
that there's some particular types of
dogs are being yeah I mean your question
was they're not going to kill any dogs
anything
by the way when 25 tinfoles were gonna
come and kill your dogs now
um I mean I I you know I'm a I'm a dog
skeptic I think they
obviously they bring a lot of droid
people but they're also
they're kind of a nuisance to people who
don't want them around and um but you
know obviously I'm able to touch the
Great British public here who love dogs
absolutely I think you know I think
inevitably this probably will I think
there will be legislation one of the
reason is that these dogs are obviously
very dangerous to a lot of other ducks
and
um and of course you know a number of
deaths
um but yeah I mean I I think the British
are probably like the most sentimental
about animals of you know there was like
Lawrence mentioned a million signatures
that petition about those two dogs that
were shot in the East End
um which is looked like clearly that was
the right thing to do and yet you know
and the police officer you're on the
police path yeah but um you know
obviously a million people will disagree
on that so yeah and you mentioned I
think a couple information be sorry but
about the fact that often these dogs are
marked as Nanny animals yeah careful
children can you tell us a bit about
that I mean I I actually got that from
Lawrence's piece and he goes into the
sort of myth of that and I think it was
sort of created in the 70s and I think
it was actually I might be wrong it was
was that actually about staffies
originally um yeah and the software I
mean if you look at these stocks as I
mean these look dogs look satanic like
you would obviously never let this this
monster near your children it's
obviously really really dangerous
um but yeah I just that's kind of a
testament to the I mean if you go to
Facebook there are all these kind of
Pitbull mom kind of web you know like
groups where they talk about how amazing
their dogs are and you know nothing will
convince these people otherwise that the
dogs are actually quite you know a bit
dangerous
um so yeah I mean that's what you're
dealing with but I think you know it
sounds perfectly reasonable you know
that
you know Kevin Lee I mean I've seen
these dogs out in my local park I've
seen one which I'm pretty sure is and
it's off the lead and I think that's
unbelievably irresponsible and that
shouldn't and people shouldn't have to
fear being attacked by a dog
um it's just going in a basic kind of
principle uh and you know if if they are
shown to be dangerous yeah and Bin laid
or you know or not allowed to you know
breed further which seems kind of very
reasonable to me I mean as interesting
Lawrence do you think the sort of the
sanctions on dog owners should be
harsher as well than than they are at
the moment if your dog does attack
someone
yeah and I think if your dog attacks
another dog
um just last week
um there was an average I think I think
every day there was a reported dog
attacked uh or actually killed by an
American Bully
um if we're talking about like
preserving other dogs
um these These dogs I mean they are bred
from dog fighting stock these were dogs
that were bred to fight other dogs which
um just goes to show that we shouldn't
be surprised if they are also uh
aggressive
um to dogs uh more generally as well as
the people and in terms of the the
sanctions on the owner I do think that
realistically we need to be much harsher
and much more
um close on enforcement there are some
rules in the dangerous dogs act at the
moment where if you allow your dog to
attack somebody and you know you haven't
gone on the sufficient control there are
actual uh penalties there but getting
the police to investigate or follow up
that's that's all incredibly difficult
and often in these kind of attacks that
happen in public uh the pattern seems to
be the dog runs off lead attack somebody
or another dog or kills another dog and
then runs off and the owner just leaves
so you know we we really need a better
way of enforcing this and really I think
adding some harsh penalties that make
people realize that having a powerful
dog means you have a bigger
responsibility over that animal
brilliant thank you Lawrence thank you
Ed
that's it for this week once again if
you enjoy spectator TV do subscribe to
our YouTube channel thank you again for
watching and do join us again next week
[Music]
thank you